les shows à la hâte en une minute et
coûte que souffle un peu vous trouvez ça
du tabac temps montre un peu je te dirai
pourquoi après oui au président pc du
tabac fin c'est là où c'était ça à la
foire d'empoigné
randy d'organes ont jeté un coup d'oeil
des fois que l'adjudant il ya
impliquerait ah oui je vous la dudh ans
à l'ouest rien de nouveau dans la pop
âgée alors et moi à lui moitié et non
t'as pas une opinion sur le fromage de
tête
bon pour toi tu as des tuyaux sur un
fromage de le cochon toit en un coup de
force mais peu tendance à la non sans
blague ou sexy cours à la cantine au bon
sens les deux formations comme une
gamelle norme et non va vous recevoir à
voir oui a signifié un parce que ça
c'est le cas de concert quand je tiens
un wiiware 20 aulas on l'a et est la
chose qui change des choses chose à
reprocher à nous soutirer
or orange encore en attendant dur on
veut lui faire un pansement buteur le
fumier enlevez-moi 7,8
oui mais voilà même résident valable
incubés vous pu mais non c'est là ce
jeudi matin tu te cigarettes
je suis moi non by toi non
assez comme ça coûte cher mais là car je
ne couperai pas du conseil décennies
quand c'est à dire aussi si chantal
valay s'éteignent je suis d'arrêt ce que
vous tombez ici à propos qu'elle s'y
passe il ya mon capitaine que j'ai plus
possible ça peut pas durer plus
longtemps avec ces deux lascars la piste
ouvertement demain mais gaillard ont
déménagé vous explique encore je fais
des blagues dans mon cas vous avez vous
expliquer c'est le l'adjudant qui a
assoupli de l'optio l'aadl ça c'est la
vérité moore capitaine je ne fais pas
mon capitaine il dit cependant un mot
qui sont amants sont ces voiliers
démarre dès mon cabinet il me donne a
démenti nous on veut nous faire passer
au conseil s'est bâti que tout français
malheureusement vous voulez moutame ou
non vous imposer le silence mois elle
comptait l'an dernier
ben ouais je vous expliquons de haut
je sortais de chez moi pour aller faire
sonner aux consignes est bon la cage les
passes inconsciente oro après les
boutiques garrett est bien vu des
cigarettes hualien pas sa casquette à
paris ce prix vous avez mis les pieds
dessus oui vous avez entendu vous avez
mis les pieds sur terre il est étudiant
en année trois quarts voulez bien vous
mettre à la position militaire
j'ai l'honneur n'a décidemment
voulez-vous électrifié de suite soit à
lomé écoutez moi j'ai horreur des fortes
têtes et les faiseurs de chic et la
prochaine fois que vous passez à fumer
ou à mettre les pieds sur vos bouts de
cigarettes
je veux être changée en pelles sucre si
je vous décerne un conseil de guerre des
mots de fripouilles tous fait la fête là
eh ben on se grouille ont ce gros mon
adjudant
voilà là
vous prétendez conseil oui oh ben ça
alors c'est à boire sa carcasse à bout
du fil et encore un tas d'ordures il
était pâle est alors celui-là lui a pas
dire mais c'est pas là